-Il est l'une des révélations
de la nouvelle Assemblée.
Ses envolées lyriques l'ont fait
remarquer dans l'hémicycle,
et pourtant, mon invité se définit
comme un techno plutôt timide.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Jean-Philippe Tanguy.
-Bonjour, M. Méric.
-Les Français vous ont découvert
à l'occasion de votre discours
prononcé à 5h du matin, après
une longue nuit de séance consacrée
au texte sur le pouvoir d'achat,
avec ce moment
qui est devenu célèbre.
-Alors,
alors, alors...
Silence !
Alors...
Exclamations
Oh, ce cri du coeur...
-M. Tanguy, s'il vous plaît.
-...qui a inspiré
beaucoup de gens
parmi nous.
Je vous en prie,
collègues de gauche.
-M. Tanguy, s'il vous plaît.
-Silence
pour la France !
Il faut un peu rigoler,
attendez !
Un peu de légèreté !
-Alors, c'était un moment
un peu inattendu,
on va dire.
Ca a fait beaucoup rire
Marine Le Pen.
La présidente de séance
rigolait aussi.
Quand vous vous mettez
dans cet état,
est-ce que vous ne risquez pas
le bon mot de trop
qui vous conduirait au dérapage ?
Vous êtes en roue libre.
-Oui, c'est pas faux.
Je vais pas vous mentir
en vous disant que c'était organisé.
Nous étions très fatigués.
Après, je pense
que l'humour,
le recul sur soi-même
permet de se sortir
de ces situations compliquées.
C'était une improvisation
puisque je ne devais pas faire
l'explication de vote.
-Ca devait être Marine Le Pen.
-Oui et, pour différentes raisons,
notamment
la tension qu'il y avait
dans l'hémicycle,
l'heure qu'il était,
elle m'a demandé
de la remplacer
et donc c'était
une improvisation.
De l'extérieur,
on n'entend pas à quel point
c'était bruyant
et à quel point
c'est une fournaise,
l'Assemblée nationale.
Donc on comprend pas
pourquoi je suis obligé
de dire cela,
mais sincèrement,
si on avait le son qu'on entendait,
on comprendrait mieux.
Les Français ont compris,
à ma surprise,
d'ailleurs,
parce que j'étais inquiet...
-De la perception ?
-Oui.
Je n'ai eu presque que,
sincèrement,
des retours positifs
parce que les Français
étaient exaspérés
de l'attitude de la NUPES.
Sur les retraites,
je me suis retenu de le redire.
-Ce qu'on voit aussi
dans cet extrait
de prise de parole,
c'est votre sens du spectacle,
le plaisir que vous prenez
à prendre la parole.
Vous avez pas toujours été
comme ça.
Vous avez fait
un travail sur vous-même
pour en arriver là ?
Ca a été...
-Oui. Moi, je trouve
que ça se voit encore, en fait.
C'est gentil quand on me dit,
comment dire,
que ça se passe bien.
Moi, je sens toujours...
Je déteste me regarder,
d'ailleurs.
Voilà, j'ai beaucoup de mal
à parler.
J'ai encore des difficultés
d'élocution.
On me dit que non,
mais je les sens une par une.
-Vous avez travaillé ça ?
-Oui,
depuis très longtemps,
depuis presque mon enfance.
Je suis très timide,
pour pas dire plus, dans mon coin.
Je me fais vraiment violence
pour prendre la parole
et c'est toujours...
Je parle vite.
Là, je fais un effort énorme
pour parler...
-Soyez vous-même.
-Il faut quand même
qu'on me comprenne.
Si je parlais
de ma façon naturelle,
j'aurais du mal
à dialoguer avec vous.
En fait,
j'ai tendance à parler vite
pour dire vite ce que j'ai à dire
et retourner...
-Pour évacuer.
-...à la solitude.
-Si on remonte
à votre adolescence,
un événement m'a étonné,
c'est la façon
dont vous êtes arrivé
au lycée Henri-IV.
Vous avez grandi
à Bures-sur-Yvette,
dans un milieu modeste.
Vous n'étiez pas vraiment programmé
pour arriver dans cet établissement.
Vous diriez
que vous avez forcé le destin ?
-Ah oui.
Sincèrement, oui.
De toute façon,
toute ma scolarité a été une épreuve
avec le système
de reproduction des élites.
Ca a aussi été des rencontres.
J'ai fait deux grandes rencontres.
C'est ma prof de piano
dont les...
-Elle vous a parlé de ce lycée.
-Oui, dont les filles avaient
des prédispositions.
Elles avaient été placées
à Henri-IV.
J'ai appris l'existence
de ce lycée.
-Comment vous êtes arrivé là ?
-Avec mon meilleur ami,
qui est toujours
mon meilleur ami
et à qui je dois beaucoup
dans le parcours
et dans la confiance
qu'il m'a permis d'avoir en moi
durant toutes ces années,
on s'est dit
qu'on allait envoyer notre dossier.
-Vous avez candidaté
sans en parler ?
-Sans en parler.
Mes parents ne voulaient pas
que j'y aille,
que je quitte Bures-sur-Yvette
pour des raisons,
comment dire,
affectueuses.
Ils pensaient
que c'était trop difficile,
qu'il fallait prendre
tous les matins
le RER,
que je n'y arriverais pas.
J'ai eu beaucoup de mal
à y arriver.
Et donc, c'est vrai que s'extraire,
j'aime pas trop ce mot,
mais il y a pas d'autre mot
à brûle-pourpoint,
s'extraire de son milieu,
rompre avec le destin
qui a été écrit
par la sociologie,
c'est difficile, et aujourd'hui,
c'est encore plus difficile.
Si j'avais 16 ans,
je n'aurais pas
le parcours que j'ai eu.
-Dans votre parcours,
après le bac,
vous avez intégré Saint-Cyr,
mais vous avez quitté cette école
très vite. Pourquoi ?
-J'ai senti
que c'était pas ma place.
C'était pas du tout contre l'armée.
C'était pas contre les officiers
qui m'ont accueilli.
Bon déjà,
j'ai un problème de discipline,
mais là, en particulier,
on m'a fait sentir que...
je ferais mieux
de faire d'autres études.
Je suis retourné en prépa
et je suis allé en école de commerce
pour servir la France
autrement.
-Vous avez fait l'ESSEC,
Sciences Po Paris.
En 2012, vous commencez un stage
chez General Electric France
aux côtés de Clara Gaymard.
C'est là que le déclic
de votre engagement politique
s'est fait, en lien
avec le dossier Alstom.
Que s'est-il passé ?
-C'est dur à expliquer
de dehors.
Mon poste était modeste.
J'étais stagiaire.
Sur les presque trois années
que j'ai passées là-bas,
j'ai vu la direction
d'une grande multinationale
et, après la crise de 2008,
un changement d'attitude
de General Electric,
qui est devenue
une entreprise prédatrice,
contre les intérêts français.
Et donc, vous êtes confronté
à la réalité.
-Vous avez eu accès
à des informations précises
sur le rachat
de la branche énergie d'Alstom
par General Electric France ?
-Oui.
-Vous auriez pu être
lanceur d'alerte.
Certains vous ont reproché
d'avoir un peu inventé un rôle
de lanceur d'alerte.
-Oui.
-Vous avez transmis
des choses
au ministère de l'Economie
pour dire ce que vous saviez
du dossier ?
-Je l'ai dit en commission d'enquête
parlementaire récemment,
j'ai dit que je pouvais le faire.
J'ai essayé d'alerter.
D'ailleurs, c'est aussi,
comment dire,
le début de mon engagement
pour M. Dupont-Aignan.
Il pourra en témoigner.
Je lui ai tout dit.
Je lui ai écrit
une lettre.
J'ai essayé d'alerter,
mais c'est intéressant,
ce que vous dites
sur les lanceurs d'alerte.
En France,
ils sont très maltraités.
On est fou, paranoïaque,
complotiste.
On n'est pas reconnu.
On n'est pas protégé.
-C'est ça qui vous a dissuadé
d'aller au bout ?
Vous avez transmis des documents
à Arnaud Montebourg, ministre
de l'Economie ?
-A un de ses collaborateurs.
M. Dupont-Aignan m'a organisé
un rendez-vous avec eux.
-Donc il a eu accès
aux informations.
-Oui.
Il y a jamais eu de retour.
Bon, c'est très compliqué
parce que c'est rigoureux.
Quand vous savez que quelque chose
va arriver,
que vous essayez d'alerter
avec vos maigres moyens,
parce que c'est même pas
David contre Goliath.
Ca n'a rien à voir
comme force.
Et après, on vous reproche
de pas avoir réussi
à aller au bout de votre démarche.
Que pouvais-je faire de plus ?
Toutes les personnes
que je pouvais alerter,
je l'ai fait.
Je n'étais qu'un modeste...
-Stagiaire.
-Voilà. En plus,
il y a le mépris de classe.
C'est important.
Il y a ce mépris.
Le fait d'être stagiaire
ou apprenti vous discrédite
de ce que vous dites.
Non. Si vous étiez
à un endroit où vous avez vu,
que vous soyez stagiaire ou cadre,
c'est pareil.
-A ce moment-là, en 2012,
vous vous engagez
aux côtés de Dupont-Aignan.
Vous avez travaillé
avec lui 8 ans.
Ca a été une bonne école
de la politique pour vous ?
-Ah oui, sincèrement.
On est différents,
avec Nicolas Dupont-Aignan,
sur la stratégie
du camp national, gaulliste,
mais c'est un excellent élu local.
Il a une maîtrise de sa capacité
à faire naître un lien de confiance
entre ses administrés et lui
qui est unique.
Il a bien géré hier.
C'est aussi un élu courageux.
Pendant des années,
il a défendu une ligne.
On n'est pas d'accord
sur la stratégie,
mais sur le fond, je ne renie
absolument rien de ces années.
-Vous avez combattu
longtemps le RN à ses côtés.
Après, vous avez tenté d'approcher
le RN avec lui.
Ca a pas fonctionné
et vous êtes parti.
Qu'est-ce qui a permis
ce rapprochement politiquement ?
-C'est simple.
C'est le fait que Marine Le Pen
ait rompu, en l'excluant,
avec Jean-Marie Le Pen.
-C'était ça qui vous bloquait ?
-Oui. C'est ce qui bloquait
tout le camp gaulliste,
que ce soit M. Dupont-Aignan
ou les électeurs
qui se reconnaissaient
dans nos valeurs qui représentaient
5 % de la population.
C'était pas la personne
de Jean-Marie Le Pen.
C'est pas une question de personne.
C'était ses provocations,
ses déclarations condamnables
et condamnées
qui, pour nous,
étaient pas nos valeurs
et empêchaient
d'arriver à la victoire.
Donc Marine Le Pen a eu
le courage de le faire.
Je trouve que le système
est dur avec elle.
On le lui reproche encore alors
qu'elle a fait ce qu'il fallait.
-Vous êtes considéré
comme son bras droit à l'Assemblée.
-Il y en a plusieurs.
Il y a Sébastien Chenu,
Laure Lavalette.
Il y en a plusieurs.
Mais moi, je travaille beaucoup
sur les questions économie
et finances.
C'est vrai qu'il y a eu
beaucoup de textes
au début de mandat
sur ces sujets-là.
Moi, j'ai une volonté.
Ce que je partage
et là où je sers Marine Le Pen,
c'est qu'elle a une volonté
de gagner
pour sauver notre pays.
J'ai un sentiment d'urgence
depuis que je suis petit :
il faut absolument gagner
au plus vite
pour éviter l'effondrement.
-Vous avez participé
au mouvement GayLib
de Sébastien Chenu
quand il était
encore à l'UMP
il y a quelques années.
En 2013, vous avez participé
aux manifestations
en faveur du mariage gay.
Vous êtes gay,
vous l'avez toujours assumé.
Vous en faites
un sujet politique ?
-Moi, je pense
qu'on ne peut pas ne pas en faire
un sujet politique.
Il faut pas lui donner
une place centrale,
mais quand vous êtes
d'une minorité,
quelle qu'elle soit,
vous ressentez
forcément les choses
d'une manière différente.
Vous vivez différemment.
Vous avez un rapport
avec la nation,
en tout cas pour moi,
qui est différent
mais très partagé
parmi les homosexuels français.
La nation est forcément
plus protectrice.
Elle est forcément...
Elle joue forcément
un rôle
dans votre idéal de vie
qui est différent.
-Est-ce dans ce sens
que vous avez posté
ce message en 2018 ?
C'était après avoir participé
à la Gay Pride :
"Fier de m'engueuler
"avec ceux qui n'ont pas compris
"que notre bonheur honorait
l'âme nationale."
Qu'entendez-vous par
"notre bonheur
"honore l'âme nationale" ?
-Nous avons beaucoup de chance
d'être français
et de vivre dans un pays
où, même s'il y a eu
des moments très douloureux,
comparé à d'autres civilisations
et d'autres pays,
l'homosexualité
était relativement tolérée.
Depuis quelques années,
en plus de ça,
on a le droit au bonheur familial,
d'avoir une vie normale.
-Cette tolérance n'a pas
toujours été présente
dans votre famille
politique.
Vous en avez été victime.
-J'ai été victime
d'une agression au couteau en 2019
de la part de groupuscules
d'extrême droite
qui sont complètement dingues.
-Vous l'aviez qualifiée
d'agression
homophobe.
-Oui,
l'objectif était
de révéler ma sexualité.
Il n'y avait rien
à révéler.
Tous ceux qui se le demandaient
ont eu la réponse.
Voilà, bon,
mais je suis pas d'accord
avec vous.
C'est une question qui traverse
les familles politiques.
-J'ai pas dit
que ça se limitait
à votre camp.
-Maintenant,
on le voit bien.
Marine Le Pen est
la championne des libertés.
Le vote des homosexuels,
en majorité,
se porte vers elle.
Quand vous regardez la gauche
et les groupes de gauche,
il y a très peu de députés
qui se revendiquent
homosexuels.
Ca devient un problème
dans une part de la société
qui n'est pas celle
qu'on attend.
-On passe à notre quiz, à présent.
J'explique le principe.
Je commence une phrase
et vous la complétez.
C'est bon, on y va ?
-Je vais essayer.
-Etre gay au RN, c'est ?
-C'est comme si
vous étiez hétérosexuel.
-Ca ne change...
-Absolument rien.
-Je ne suis pas
à la commission des finances, mais ?
-Je le serai un jour.
-La prochaine fois.
-Je ne sais pas.
Mais...
Je vais vous surprendre,
mais Eric Coquerel
fait un bon travail.
-Ah ! Quand je prends la parole
dans l'hémicycle,
ce que j'aime avant tout,
c'est ?
-Défendre les idées.
-Très bien.
Merci beaucoup.
-Merci à vous.
-Merci d'être venu dans l'émission.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...